this is exciting to be talking about
season two of this knowing full well
that
we're gonna be getting a season three
too
this is pretty it's pretty amazing
not only are we getting it we've already
shot it we've already said the can
well
you know one thing i'm super curious
about is like as a viewer
you guys are taking us on all these
twists and turns there's i mean there's
a lot to
you know when you say expect unexpected
that's kind of like what happens in the
show when you're reading scripts
are you going on that same ride are you
going whoa like i can't believe that
this is happening for this character
that this twist is coming
yeah i mean that's pretty much the
closest we get to that first yeah blush
look at you know how it feels to watch
something and for to be a surprise i
mean it's never quite that clean because
you always hear like
little rumors and like did you hear
maybe this is gonna happen in a few
episodes
um
usually the thing that's the most
surprising
is the way things happen uh and and the
series of events that leads up to big
things um
and
i actually will say that as the show
went on and as we got even into season
three uh
it became
i don't know if i changed or if the show
changed but like i became more easily
surprised
like i would read i would read things
and be like oh my god
in a way that i never in a way that i
never used to so i don't know i don't i
don't know how to account for that i
this um one thing i did appreciate about
carlton cues and meredith avril is they
they
um sat down with me or us different
castmates and um
kind of gave us a general overview of
what the arc would be so
um i did appreciate that i had some
sense of the shape as i was starting in
on the season both season one and season
two season three was less that way
because it was like we did shoot him
back to back and they were still writing
the script so it felt like season three
it was a little bit more of a surprise
in terms of like
i can't wait to get that next script um
but the first two seasons felt more like
shooting a film or something where you
kind of knew the body of the work
um but season three i will say i was
surprised
greatly a couple of times and it it is
fun to have that experience
the one
pure experience of reading the script
and you get your reaction that this is
going to be as close as the audience
reaction you know if you're interested
in and i'm very much a fan of the show
as well as being in it so to have that
initial reaction and then sort of
you know file that away and then go and
shoot the show because shooting your
role is a very in the story is a very
different a different feeling than you
know my initial reaction
you're like two different things yeah
um something i love about even just the
approach to
uh the keys and what they do is just you
know imagine what would you do
in real life with these kids like what
would be for you the most practical key
that you would want to have because
you're like oh i could use this this
makes life easier and then what's the
one key that you'd be like i would never
in my life
ever touch this
i mean definitely the most practical key
is the anywhere key
i mean definitely
it's like it would solve so many
problems it would make life
so much easier i mean almost no more jet
lag
yeah but also like you don't need like
that's like the extreme example but
think of like you know walking down to
like the grocery stores you could just
pop it's so easy
it's
so practical the most useless one for
sure is the mirror key i think
i mean it's like
what it's like an entrance to like a
mirror prison world like what would you
ever use that for you know i don't have
any enemies
but i know what i'm just gonna say good
for you good good i'm like i mean yeah
that you're like
yeah me being like as far as i know
right
yeah
i think uh probably the key that i
wouldn't want any responsibility for is
the
omega key
um that that uh
you know is where all the bad stuff
comes from like the door that seals that
portal to that world
um
i i mean what if you lose it
someone wants to borrow it
the door i don't know the you know the
block breaks and then you're responsible
for all that stuff back there just do i
don't want anything to do with it so
you're worried that someone someone
might want to borrow it yeah
i'm just making this up you're like who
are you lending it to that's the other
thing you just say no just say no
just i don't want the responsibility or
authority to have that key
100
well it's i think it's so exciting for
fans to be able to uh catch up with you
guys again in season two and knowing
full well that they're they're gonna get
more with this season three thank you so
much for the time all the best thank you